[Music]  do you know what it is to make your  dreams come true do you see me working  dusters I don't deserve really oh I love  you so much but you don't know me  I want to know what the deal is  when is crazy bartender this kind of  thing fits my reputation he's gotta go  oh no soda your girlfriend has secrets  he lost me taking hymns in [ __ ] off  something going on you need to maintain  sense a humor back  you're gonna give me some trouble big  boy are you gonna channel that famous  Amish serenity  I need to tell you something  this is gonna stop right now Blaine a  secret anymore  you do anything for her  say your soil  I can t talk because  you  [Music]  [Music]